opening statements get underway next
week in the trial of former minneapolis
police officer derek
chauvin accused in the death of george
floyd last may
chauvin faces murder in the second
degree and other charges
in a case that launched protests around
the nation and around the world
here to tell us what we can expect is
cbs news legal analyst ricky clement
ricky good morning
good morning so what are the charges
that derek chovin
is facing and what are the possible
penalties
derek shoving is facing three charges
the highest charge
is murder in the second degree it has a
penalty maximum
of 40 years this is not premeditated
not intentional murder the theory of
this charge
is felony murder and the underlying
felony is an intentional
assault that actually reached a point
of putting george floyd in substantial
danger of losing his life
the second charge underneath the first
is murder in the
third degree that charge in minnesota
carries a penalty of 25 years it always
was used for a reckless act
involving more than one person like
shooting into a group
of people a crowd of people but the
intermediate appellate court said
in this case that it can be used and so
it
is being used and then finally we have
manslaughter in the second degree a
10-year maximum penalty
and when you look at that that is a much
lower standard we're talking about
culpable negligence that is putting
someone at an
unreasonable risk of serious bodily
injury or death
if he is convicted of either of the
murder counts
murder in the second degree murder in
the third degree
the sentencing guidelines means he would
do something like
ten and three quarters to fifteen years
in prison
ricky what's the what's the strongest
argument in your judgment from
the defense and what do you expect from
them and then also what's the strongest
argument for the prosecution
the prosecution obviously has a strong
argument simply by that video and if i'm
the prosecutor
i wait in my opening statements for
almost
nine minutes in silence or if given
permission
i put forth that video that is a very
long time
this is not a police officer making a
split-second decision
but the defense has a very viable
two-pronged attack the first is cause of
death was it
in fact the knee on the neck of george
floyd put there by derek chauvin
that caused the death or was it his
condition
underneath of heart disease plus the
ingestion of a very great amount of
drugs methamphetamine
and the finding of 11 nanograms
of fentanyl three nanograms
if someone died at home alone would be
considered a drug overdose
second prong of the defense jeff has to
do with the use of force
and his training was the force that he
used
reasonable should it have been used by a
police officer in that
situation and there will be testimony by
experts on both sides
whether or not this was part of his
training and therefore he thought it was
perfectly reasonable
or whether it was in fact beyond the
pale
perhaps even because of the time
involved
going close to nine minutes is a
phenomenal amount of time
ricky no sooner did jury selection get
started
then the city settled a civil case
with a family for 27 million dollars
will this be an issue can chovin get a
fair trial considering this
this will certainly be an issue for
appeal you can't get the elephant
out of the room most of those jurors had
a negative impression of derek chovin
when you hear
27 million dollar settlement you have to
believe he is guilty of something
very very serious ricky kliman as always
thank you very much
thank you